marx en europe n'a pas fait appel huit
ans de prison ferme une peine qu'il va
devoir purger mais qu'en est il des
dommages et intérêts le tribunal
correctionnel de nevers a fixé le
montant des indemnités pour chaque
victime
mais l'ex dentiste de château chinon est
insolvable et son assurance ne versera
pas un centime
la solidarité nationale doit se mettre
en marche c'est le fonds de garantie des
victimes qui va devoir payer et
déterminer le montant de ces indemnités
c'est un fonds publics et qui permet
d'indemniser des victimes d'une
infraction lorsque l'auteur n'est pas
solvable on n'a pas été identifié et ce
même fonds de garantie et on le fait
aujourd'hui financent les indemnisations
pour les victimes du terrorisme
lors du procès en mars dernier la
demande de reconnaissance du préjudice
d'anxiété a été déposée par une
trentaine de victimes
il n'a finalement pas été retenue par le
tribunal l'objectif étant pour les
victimes de démontrer à la cour que
c'est tout à fait spécifique que c'est
tout à fait exceptionnel ce qui leur est
arrivé et que ça nécessite une
indemnisation particulière est pas la
même chose qui on a une fracture de la
mâchoire qu'on tombe d'une échelle
si on a la mâchoire abîmé au décours
d'un acte 2 3 il a fait un point très
important notamment dans la confiance
que les patients peuvent avoir dans les
différents intervenants médicaux ces
victimes ont donc fait appel pour
obtenir la reconnaissance de ce
préjudice supplémentaire pour le moment
aucune indemnité n'a été versée un
premier délibéré sera rendu par la cie
vie le 7 septembre prochain